was passiert da gerade mit den
Wärmepumpen was ist das für eine Idee
die da gerade aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium kommt und wie ist
das eigentlich so unausgegoren so früh
an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt werden das
durchgesteckt wer war das da kommen wir
immer spekulieren darüber werdest du
gewollt aber jemand von den Grünen weiß
sich ja nicht aber einmal das ganze
sozusagen gerne koordiniert und
abgesprochen
dass so ein wichtiges Ding nach der
gasumlage die auch schon kein
Geniestreich war sage ich jetzt mal
vorsichtig das jetzt wieder Sonne jetzt
haben wir
Wärmepumpen geht naja wir haben mit
Punkten Geld ist ein bisschen hochgehen
aber ich meine Regierung
gibt es halt nicht nur zwei drei Leute
und es sind halt auch nicht alles grüne
und zudem haben sie dann Verdacht
jedenfalls keine grünen und alles andere
sozusagen wollen wir einfach spekulativ
auf die Seite legen aber wenn man es
einfach nicht wissen und deswegen macht
es auch keinen Sinn Redezeit drüber zu
verschwenden also das Klima scheint
nicht gut zu sein bei dem Thema Robert
Habeck heute ich zitiere es kann nicht
sein dass in einer fortschrittskoalition
nur ein Koalitionspartner für den
Fortschritt verantwortlich ist und die
anderen für die Verhinderung von
Fortschritt deswegen jetzt noch mal die
Frage was einer aus der FDP ich glaube
es bringt nichts ich kann nur sagen es
war keiner von den Grünen und es bringt
auch nichts zu spekulieren sondern man
muss sich doch klar machen worum es geht
es geht darum wenn sie sich den neuesten
ipc-recht anschauen dass die Klimakrise
aus der Kontrolle zu geraten rot der
Gardasee hat jetzt schon so wenig Wasser
wir schon lange nicht mehr hatte und es
ist nicht hoch Sommer in Frankreich gibt
es Riesenprobleme weil die Dürre ihr
plötzlich voneinander wintertüre
sprechen
und dann Wärmebereich verursacht je
nachdem wie man es rechnet aber circa 40
Prozent des CO2-Ausstoßes und deswegen
geht es darum den CO2 Ausstoß auch in
diesem Bereich runterzubringen und
deshalb ist die Regelung das denn einem
die Heizung kaputt geht und sie auch
nicht mehr reparierbar ist und man auch
die Übergangsfrist von drei Jahren oder
sogar von fünf Jahren nicht nutzen will
dann baut man eine Heizung in seine
hauseintes zu immerhin 65% aus
erneuerbaren Energien gespeist wird also
keine Ölheizung mehr und auch keine
Gasheizung mehr also mal so im Bestand
können Sie sogar eine hybridheizung
einbauen aber es muss halt zu 65%
CO2-frei sein wie sie das technisch
umsetzen
viel Glück es wird immer so getan als
wenn in unserem Land alle unfäh um
nichts zustande bringen und ich finde
man hatte die Debatte auch zum Beispiel
als es darum ging dass wir aus dem
Erdgas rauskommen letztes Jahr um die
Zeit waren wir noch fast zu 55 Prozent
abhängig beim Erdgas und dann hat man
gesagt wir schaffen das wir kommen da
aus der Abhängigkeit raus dann ist es
viel Glück funktioniert eh nicht in
Deutschland dauert alles so ewig die
Regierung kann es nicht und wir haben
das alles geschafft und so bin ich mir
sicher dass wir auch das wenn man die
Gesetze richtig macht bei der wärmewende
hin also die Regierung kann es nicht ne
sagt nicht irgendjemand sondern die
Regierung jemand wie Stefan weil ja der
der SPD angehört und die Teil ich glaube
weil
der Gesetzentwurf von seiner SPD
amtskollegins die immerhin die
bauministerin ist mindestens so
verantwortlich wird wie von den Grünen
da gab es ja auch ganz interessante
twitter-
sind denn eigentlich sozusagen gemerkt
haben dass sie eigentlich damit vor
allem ihre bauministerin angreifen und
ich glaube sozusagen das haben die
beiden Ministerpräsidenten nicht so
richtig gemerkt gehabt das ist ja eine
katastrophale Eindruck der da entsteht
also weil sagt
diese Zeitplanung ist eine realistisch
und stiftet am Ende mehr Schaden als
Nutzen ich habe noch ein anderes sehr
deutliches Zitat dieser Entwurf ist
klimapolitisch gut gemeint
wirtschaftlich und sozial ist das Echo
verheerend diese Pläne müssen zurück in
die montage-halle und grundlegend
überarbeitet werden eine oberflächliche
Reparatur wird nicht reichen sagt wer
ner
Finanzminister dann ist aber immer
interessant zuzusagen ist immer
interessant dass die Leute das alles ja
mit beschlossen haben das ist ja gar
kein neuer Plan ich glaube bei der FDP
weißt du eine gewisse Panik gibt noch
eine ganze Reihe von verlorenen
Landtagswahlen nach deutlich
schlechteren Umfragen und einfach die
Hoffnung durch klare Abgrenzung von den
Koalitionspartnern seine Wähler
zurückzuholen ich glaube nicht dass das
funktioniert aber das ist erstmal die
Frage der FDP also müssen die Christian
Lindner fragen warum er etwas sagt was
er
letztes Jahr
vor Monaten mit beschlossen hat und ich
mein eins darf man auch nicht vergessen
es geht hier um Öl und Gasheizungen
können wir uns erinnern was worüber wir
vorher gerade geredet haben über den
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine und
unsere extreme Abhängigkeit von fossilen
Energien es geht ja nicht nur um die
Klimakrise sondern auch von diesen
Abhängigkeiten
von diesen Abhängigkeiten so ein
bisschen ja lass uns jetzt einmal zur
Teil gehen Frau Höning bitte aber dass
der Satz im Koalitionsvertrag steht mit
20-24 und FDP und SPD den Grünen
Unterschied auch unterschrieben haben
ist ja das eine aber das ist ja nicht
das was die Menschen interessiert die
Menschen interessiert da kommt ein
Gesetz ich soll wenn ich im nächsten
Jahr nur eine neue Heizung braucht muss
ich darf ich keine gastheizung mehr
nehmen muss eine Wärmepumpe nehmen und
wenn ich dann den Handwerker Frage wie
lange Lieferzeit hast du sagte zehn
Monate und das sagt nicht der andere
Monate oder 15 Monate sondern das sagt
die Verbraucherzentrale deren Chefin
eine grüne ist
was ich auch da interessant finde das
weitere Thema sind die Kosten die
Verbraucherzentrale rechnet uns auch
schön vor was das kostet 30.000 bis
40.000 Euro brutto es gibt ja eine Reihe
von staatlichen Förderungen sehr schön
dann sind wir bei 25.000 Euro 25.000
Euro wer hat das in dem Land hier um
eine neue Heizung einzubauen und
natürlich
zwingt niemand aus der Bundesregierung
die Leute die Heizung auszureißen nur 25
000 € in diesen Zeiten und das ganze
noch ohne Not es hätte andere Wege
gegeben um den Gebäude Sektor endlich zu
mehr Klimaschutz zu zwingen denn das das
Fenster für den Klima Schutz sich
schließt ist ja vollkommen unbestritten
sie gehen nur auf den völlig falschen
Weg Sie gehen auf Verbote und
Ordnungspolitik und viel sinnvoller wäre
es auf Anreize zu gehen
also ich meine das wäre wirklich schlimm
wenn es so wäre wie sie gerade
darstellen das stimmt halt einfach nicht
nach dem Gesetzentwurf der noch nicht
fertig ist steht halt was anderes drin
da steht erstens drin dass die 65%
erneuerbare Energien machen müssen und
nicht 100% da steht sozusagen auch nicht
drin dass sie eine Wärmepumpe einbauen
müssen da steht auch nicht drin dass
wenn das kaputt gegangen ist sieht es
sofort machen müssen sondern sie haben
im Minimum eine Übergangsfrist von drei
Jahren und da können Sie auch andere
Lösungen machen und sie können sogar
eine hybridheizung einbauen sie können
Pellet einbauen sie können wenn sie sich
sozusagen
[Musik]
hieß es für alle müssten Wärmepumpen
einbauen jetzt stellen wir fest das
stimmt nicht sondern 65 Prozent der muss
erneuerbar sein das heißt dass 35% noch
Fossil sein darf dann
nicht es ist plötzlich die redet dass
alle Pellets einbauen müssen nicht alle
wissen
realistische Option ist außer fernwärmer
wenn sie grünen beheizt wird ja weil
Pellets ja vom Bundesumweltamt
abgesehen
davon
bei der Fernwärme wir sind sozusagen bei
strombetriebenen Heizungen die auch
möglich sind und die du hast es gibt
also man nennt das Nachtspeicheröfen das
ist eine Technik die ist seit über 50
Jahren gibt die wollen ja zum
Nachtspeicher zurück
meine Frage gewesen also wenn sie sagen
es muss niemand sagt dass es Wärmepumpen
sein sollen wir wollen aber auch kein Öl
mehr wir wollen kein Gas mehr
dann wollen sie mit Nachtspeicher jetzt
Deutschland retten also sie können
sozusagen mit strombetriebenen Heizungen
gerade wenn es nicht unbedingt
Nachtspeicher ist sondern wenn es uns
endlich gelingt was auch verschlappt
verschlampt worden ist nämlich endlich
dass wir an das Stromnetz digitalisieren
was wir jetzt auch angehen dann können
Sie das zum Beispiel mit Überschussstrom
machen bevor sie sozusagen die
Windkraftanlage abschalten
nutzen Sie besser den Strom und laden
damit
wir haben ja noch nicht mal 50% Ökostrom
in Deutschland wenn sie jetzt zur
Nachtspeicherheizung zurückkommen kommt
der von den Braunkohlekraftwerken am
Niederrhein und in der lausitze was ist
jetzt sozusagen ihr Vorwurf das hier zu
strengt sind oder dass wir zu wenig sind
dass sie das mit dem falschen Mittel
machen dass sie Kinderpolitik mit rechts
kommen
sie sozusagen
festgelegt um entsprechend ähm
Freunde des CO2-Preis kommen immer bald
mit festgelegt wie hoch soll er denn
sein ich bin nicht die Institution die
das so
einrichten dass man den co2-ausschuss
entsprechend senkt und das wäre
sinnvoller als jetzt Millionen Euro
dafür bin ich ja und das ist auch nicht
zuständig das mag sein und wenn man sie
doch mal eine Zahl hochhalten
nämlich die Zahlen die man nutzen müsste
während zu dramatisch hoch das ist
grundlegend und sozial wäre dass
Menschen mit geringeren Einkommen dass
sie ganz sicher nicht leisten können und
sie hätten einen Shitstorm der in dem
Vergleich dazu das was mir jetzt bei den
Wärmepumpen mehr absolut harmlos ist
weil ich die Zahlen durch die Decke
gehen würden und deswegen weiß man und
das ist sozusagen nicht funktioniert das
ist ja immer das auch das hat mir im
Wahlkampf auch mit der fdpd FDP hat auf
der einen Seite gesagt die Grünen wollen
total dafür sorgen dass die
Energiepreise doch die Decke gehen und
wenn du dann gefragt hast okay aber ihr
wollt doch ein hohen CO2-Preis dann ist
es ja das hat überhaupt nichts
miteinander zu tun das stimmt aber nicht
je höher der CO2-Preis ist desto höher
sind am Ende die Energiepreise
das was sie gerade vorschlagen ist durch
die Decke gehender Benzinpreis durch die
Decke gehen der Dieselpreis durch die
Decken gehen der Heizölpreis durch die
Decke gehender Gaspreis das ist ihr
Vorschlag und das heißt es trifft dann
nicht mehr nur die Leute deren Heizung
kaputt geht und denen man damit guten
Geld helfen kann eine neue Heizung war
es trifft dann alle Besitzer von allen
Heizungen und das was wir im Herbst
erlebt haben als die Leute Paniker haben
hatten wegen dem russischen
Angriffskrieg dass Sie Ihre Heizkosten
nicht mehr eine das setzen Sie dann per
Gesetz
also diese Geschichte lassen wir schon
lange nicht mehr erzählen nicht das ist
da alte Trick der Leute die immer sagen
wir mal neben dem marktbasierte Lösung
und sich dann weigern zu sagen wie hoch
der Preis ist nächstes bedeutet
massenhaft Leute per Gesetz in die
Insolvenz das ist ihr Vorschlag ich kann
aber auch darin bestehen Frau Höning den
Trick vorzuwerfen und dabei sozusagen
die Antwort auf die Frage großräumig zum
fahren wie sie es jetzt gerade mehrfach
gemacht haben aber sie werden uns gleich
eine Antwort darauf geben müssen welche
Heizung genau dann wirklich zum Einsatz
kommt erst die Frage gespannt
da haben sie Mechanismus des co2-preises
nicht verstanden und den können Sie
vielleicht im Wirtschaft Gutachten der
Wirtschaftsweise noch mal nachlesen der
Witz an dem CO2-Preis ist ja dass er ein
Ziel vorgibt und dann wird man dort die
CO2 Kosten einsparen wo es am
günstigsten ist und mit dieser
Ordnungspolitik
Maß der Stadt sich an zu sagen dass in
der Altbauwohnung oder in dem alten Haus
die co2-sparung am günstigsten sei und
das ist eben der Fehler und der gehen
überhaupt nicht die Benzinpreise und
alles in einer Tour durch die Decke
sondern da sucht der Markt den Bereich
raus wo es am günstigsten und das könnte
zum Beispiel dazu führen dass man sagt
man braucht nicht mehr so viel
braunkohlestrom aus der Lausitz da hat
man halt nur das politische Problem dass
man die Kohlekraftwerke da aus
politischen Gründen nicht abschalten
soll also gucken sie noch mal nach und
es ist wirklich ein feines Instrument
wie auch die Preise in der
Marktwirtschaft ja
sehr freundlich aber sehr saftiger vor
wo freundlich vorgetragen aber im
Fernsehen saftig sie haben das CO2
Bepreisung nicht verstanden
auf die Braunkohlekraftwerke sind
CO2-Preis drauf weil nämlich das ist der
Bereich wo bereits ein CO2-Preis haben
also deswegen
einfach falsch
verstanden habe
will ich jetzt nicht bewerten nämlich
wie gesagt auf dem Braunkohle
dass man das endlich auf die Bereiche
Verkehr und Gebäude ausweitet wo ja
leider besonders wenig getan wurde im
Klimaschutz und schade dass die Grünen
sich das Verkehrsministerium nicht
genommen haben wir wissen dass die
Verkehrspolitik so elementar ist für die
Klimawende und die Grünen haben sich
leider nicht nehmen können genommen
gerade das wäre ihr Spielfeld gewesen
wenn sie sozusagen noch mehr Werbung
machen würden für die Grünen hat man
vielleicht nächstes
mal sagen als Empathie getante
Niedertracht ja letzten Endes weil sie
genau weiß dass ihr wundert Punkt ist
sie wollten ja selber Verkehrsminister
werden
[Musik]
nie funktioniert
ich hätte trotzdem gerne Antwort auf die
Frage wie heißen wir ganz viel machen
wir das ist ja schon interessant Sie
sagen co2-bepreisung wollen wir so nicht
sagen weil dann gibt es einen
aufschalter draußen also offensichtlich
haben sie Angst vor ihren eigenen
Wählern nein wir wollen sozusagen
deutlich zu sagen Wärmepumpen darauf
läuft hinaus das ist sehr interessant
und stattdessen doch stattdessen geben
Sie eine relativ nebulöse Antwort was
man alles machen kann hybridheizungen
bisschen Nachtspeicher plötzlich reden
wir über Pellets das ist doch nicht hier
ernst wir müssen noch immer irgendwann
dieses Land waren kriegen oder eine
echte ökologische Wände hinkriegen wenn
sie sagen mit Strom heizen würde ich
immer noch mal einwenden auch
wärmepumpen sind nichts anderes als
Heizen mit Strom
sie nehmen sozusagen ja auch die
Umgebungswärme ja ja ja genau am Ende
geht es darum mit Strom zu heizen es
geht das verstehen viele nicht weil man
mit dieser Technik noch wenig Erfahrung
hat aber es geht doch darum dieses Land
definitiv an allen Enden elektrifizieren
das bedeutet wir werden sehr viel Strom
brauchen und wenn wir Wärmepumpen
einsetzen dann ist es sozusagen ein
Hebel um die Menge an Strom noch mal
nach oben zu bringen und etwas weniger
Strom zu bezahlen aber am Ende heizen
wir mit Strom Punkt Ende in ganz vielen
Bereichen ja aber das ist ja auch gar
keine Pumpen hinaus es wahrscheinlich
nicht nur es wird sozusagen es gibt fast
nur nein ähm das ist im Grunde falsch
nämlich ich komme zum Beispiel aus dem
Landkreis München hier ganz umfangreich
mit dir Termin in München ja da geht das
um biologische Besonderheiten wir haben
wenn man sich das anschaut ungefähr 25%
der Wärme Energie könnte man in
Deutschland ökonomisch sinnvoll mit
ihrer Termin schaffen deshalb exakt der
Gesetzentwurf ist halt anders als er
hier dargestellt wird weil ich im
Gesetzentwurf steht drin 65% erneuerbare
Energie bitte auf dem Land nicht München
nicht große Geothermie Unterlagen
wirklich sehr sehr tief gebohrt sehr
aufwendig noch toll noch teurer als
Wärmepumpe als Luftwärmepumpe kann sich
ein Privatmensch natürlich überhaupt
nicht leisten nein
da wo ihre Kundschaft in der Regel nicht
sitzt der ganz normale Häuslebauer wie
kriegt er in Zukunft sein Haus warm das
ist doch die Frage wie macht er das das
kommt sozusagen darauf an also zum
Beispiel
Sauerlach wo ich herkomme ursprünglich
das ist klassisches Land da haben wir
inzwischen zu den einzelnen Häusle
Bauern eine ferne Leitung und zwar mit
einem Biomasse Heizkraftwerk
am Strom aber sozusagen nein
jede Lösung sozusagen
haben nicht alle auf der einen Seite
heißt
auf deine Seite wird behauptet wir
schreiben eine Technik vor dann sage ich
im Gesetzentwurf nein ist nicht so wir
haben gesagt im Gesetzentwurf steht drin
65% erneuerbare Energien also CO2 frei
und dann heißt das Öl heißt keine
Heizung wenn ich heute eine neue CO2
drin ich hatte neugasheizung kaufe was
kostet die das heißt
40.000 Euro 20.000 Euro 10.000
€. was kostet die Installation einer
Wärmepumpe was kostet 40.000 brutto es
kommen dann allerdings diese angedachten
Förderhilfen der Bundesregierung hinzu
dann sind wir seit 20 25
rechnen ist die Wärmepumpe trotzdem
hören Installationskosten bereits jetzt
kostengünstiger als eine gashalt ich
rede aber jetzt über den Bestand ja und
im Bestand Leute in den 60er Jahre
Häusern wohnen die Leute die in
Mietwohnungen in Berlin in Hamburg in
München woandersleben so was machen die
also jetzt nehmen wir mal theoretisch an
denen geht
die Heizung kaputt
also nämlich wenn sie einfach jetzt eine
Gasheizung haben sondern die zehn Jahre
alt ist dann dürfen sie die 20 Jahre
weiter betreiben das heißt sie haben
sehr viel Zeit sich darauf vorzubereiten
also 20 Jahre weiter können Sie das
machen aber wenn Ihre Heizung jetzt
kaputt geht nicht um diesen Fall geht es
oder Ihre Heizung ist schon 30 Jahre alt
es sind ja nicht auch alle Menschen
deswegen ist es ja viele Menschen viele
Menschen aber deswegen ist es ja auch
falsch dass alle Menschen sofort eine
Wärmepumpe kriegen was machen die
wenn sie sozusagen kann gar keine andere
Möglichkeit haben dann haben die die
Möglichkeit eine Wärmepumpe einzubauen
wenn es schwierig ist haben sie drei
Jahre Übergangsfrist drei drei Jahre
Übergangsfrist und es wird ganz
umfangreiche
Fördermaßnahmen geben so dass es am Ende
für die Leute
nicht entkern teurer wird
die bestehende gasheits kann man doch
nicht ernsthaft seriös an dem Punkt so
versprechen wenn sie wenn
einmal meine Argument bitte einmal hören
sie bauen eine Wärmepumpe ein die kostet
ungefähr 40.000 € mit der Wärmepumpe ist
es ja nicht getan der hängt ja noch ganz
viel dran wenn man sich mit dem Thema
mal wirklich seriös beschäftigt merkt
man das funktioniert in so einem 60er
Jahre Haus funktioniert das gar nicht
weil Wärmepumpe bedeutet Sie müssen
viele kleine Stellschrauben drehen damit
sie das Haus dann warm kriegen bedeutet
idealerweise heizen Sie nicht mit
irgendwelchen Heizkörpern sondern mit
einer Fußbodenheizung die meisten weil
die mit niedrigeren Temperaturen
funktioniert
das heißt Sie müssen da eine
Fußbodenheizung reinbringen sie müssen
Ihre Fenster dämmen sie müssen Ihr Dach
dämmen und sie kaufen sich diese
Wärmepumpe am Ende sind sie bei einer
Investition diese weit jenseits von
40.000 Euro wer zahlt das deswegen noch
mal die Frage wer kann ernsthaft
versprechen dass das nicht mehr kostet
oder dass das sozial fair passieren soll
dass Menschen nicht immer von der
Situation stellt sie sagen okay ich muss
jetzt die Heizung austauschen ich habe
diese drei Jahre ich habe aber nicht das
Geld ich kann nicht 100.000 €
investieren und mein Haus jetzt
Wärmepumpen fit zu machen
Härtefallregelung aber sie haben halt
auch das Problem dass und das davon
haben wir vorher gesprochen das Gas und
Erdöl auch knapp wird auch immer teurer
wird manche wollen sozusagen eigentlich
schon CO2 Preis auch noch oben
drauflegen die Amerikaner erschließen
oder hast ja gerade ein gigantisches
Erdöl fällt und jetzt
freigegebenprojekt kennen Sie also um
die Klimakrise ich habe nicht das Gefühl
das Öl knapp wird das Gefühl habe ja
aber auch nicht billig wird und die
Klimakrise sozusagen auch vor der Tür
steht immer natürlich können wir sagen
mit all den Beispiel wir werden die
Häuser nicht gedämmt kriegen wir werden
die Erneuerbaren Heizungen nicht
eingebaut kriegen wir geben das ganz
schlimm
nein das stimmt in meinen die Probleme
sind überhaupt gigantisch gigantisch gib
doch die Probleme ja natürlich gibt's
die Profile bitte wir sind uns alle
einig über das Ziel ich und ich glaube
jeder jeder hier und auch jeder der
zuschaut hat verstanden dass wir so
nicht weitermachen können gar keine
Frage nur die Frage ist am meine für
mich warum können wir das nicht
tatsächlich mal wie Frau Höning zum
Beispiel sagt tatsächlich den Kräften
des Marktes überlassen sagen wir müssen
Anreize schaffen warum müssen wir
stattdessen wieder so so so so so so
super engagiert sagen 2024 maximal 25
und dann gibt's dann ganz harten cut
während der Rest der Welt China
verbrennt Öl und Kohle und Gas die
Amerikaner schließen riesige Ölfelder in
Alaska gerade das heißt wir werden von
dem Argument sozusagen kriegen den Kampf
insgesamt 2 % des CO2 Ausstoßes weltweit
aus ich kenne all die Argumente ich weiß
auch dass es eine sozusagen historische
Schuld gibt alles gut aber ist es
ernsthaft so dass wir den Wohlstand und
auch den sozialen Frieden in einem Land
gefährden wollen um etwas zu erreichen
was am Ende weltweit betrachtet nicht
den ausschlaggebend was Sie jetzt damit
sagen ist dass es im Grunde egal ist und
ihr es einfach sein nicht doch in der
Konsequenz
das ist das was ich sage es geht
sozusagen darum nicht dass wir heute
oder morgen klimaneutral wir reden von
20 45 und wie gesagt der Weg der hier
vorgeschlagen wird der ist halt wenn man
es ernst meinen würde und deswegen ist
er halt um Größenordnungen und sozialer
weil er nämlich auf den Schlag für alle
Menschen sofort das Heizen unbezahlbar
macht und das können sie da brauchen sie
subventionsmittel dann wieder drunter
gegen die gleichzeitig den CO2-Preis
unwirksam machen das haben wir alles im
Herbst letzten Jahres erlebt wo die
Preise entsprechend durch die Decke
gegangen sind und deswegen fängt man im
nächsten Jahr an bei den Leuten wo die
Heizung kaputt geht wo es keine
Härtefallregelung gibt wo es wo das
ganze darstellbar ist fängt man an und
die bekommen entsprechende Unterstützung
man kann natürlich auch sagen im Moment
des zu kompliziert im nächsten Jahr ist
zu kompliziert im übernächsten Jahr ist
der kompliziert und deswegen sozusagen
fangen wir besser okay an und deshalb
ist der Vorschlag wir fangen jetzt an im
nächsten Mal an diesem Gesetzentwurf ist
dass er das Problem ja auch noch
schlimmer macht weil was passiert im
Vorgriff auf die drohen das Drohne aus
vergashaltung kaufen die Leute wie blöd
jetzt Gasheizung das heißt wir bekommen
mehr Gasheizung als nötig und es kann
auch überhaupt gar nicht im Interesse
der Grünen sein also das Handwerkliche
Kernprobleme daran ist dass man einfach
diese Übergangsfrist viel zu kurz
gesetzt hat wenn wir da von einem
Zeitraum fünf Jahren gesprochen hätten
zehn Jahren dann genug
Anpassungsmöglichkeiten gegeben dann
wäre ja auch längst die
wärmepumpenwirtschaft hochgelaufen dann
sehr das ganze schon anders aus Leute
die es einbauen wir im Bereich Heizung
Sanitär aber die letzten zehn Jahren
zehn Prozent des Personals verloren die
sind weg genau da hätten es ist einfach
vollkommen zu machen ihr Problem ist die
Stellen ist immer super als wenn
sozusagen im nächsten Jahr alle Leute
ihre Heizungen rausreißen müssten
und das merke ich ja bei den Leuten wenn
man mit den Leuten spricht die haben den
Eindruck es wird von ihnen verlangt dass
sie alle ihre Heizungen verstehen die
Leute müssen und das ist sozusagen
die erzählt wird und das ist es nicht
sondern es geht darum dass bei den
Menschen wo die Heizung kaputt geht und
die deshalb oder 30 Jahre alt ist und
die deshalb eine neue Heizung brauchen
dass sie eine Heizung einbauen die zu 65
Prozent mit erneuerbaren Energien
betrieben wird und das wird das nicht
schaffen sollten mit entsprechender
finanzieller Unterstützung für diese
Gruppe von Menschen das halte ich für
Ark klein gedacht da bin ich
optimistisch dass wir dann feststellen
werden wir haben es doch geschafft wer
bezahlt das
insgesamt die Gesellschaft schon davon
ja er hat es ja sozusagen im März glaube
ich letzten Jahres mit beschlossen
dieses Gesetz muss so wie es ist zurück
in die montage-halle also ist ja noch
nicht
und im übrigen sagt ja die
bundesbahnministerin sozusagen
durchgestochen worden in einem nicht
fertigen Zustand da steht sozusagen die
Unterstützung ist frei was hast du
katastrophal Wirkung ist das
katastrophal in der Wirkung ist es so
als wären sie nicht mehr eine Regierung
so wirkt das damit eine riesen Aufregung
im Land eine riesen Diskussion darüber
und sie sagten gerade zurecht Frau
geibels die Bundesministerin schreibt
auf Ihre Internetseite möglichst 2024 wo
interessant ist wie die kleinen nur
Angst
weil sie sozusagen schon drei Jahre
Übergangsfrist drin haben weil sie wenn
sie sich an die Fernwärme anschließen
sogar fünf Jahre Übergangsfrist haben
ich weiß ehrlich sagte warum sie immer
versuchen dieses Gesetz völlig anders
darzustellen als es ist bisher bekannt
ist und ich sag es ist halt auch noch
von irgendjemand und man kann es einfach
hart aussprechen wahrscheinlich FDP oder
SPD
das ganze sozusagen gut vorbereitet und
gern gemacht hätte um all die Fragen
sozusagen beantworten zu können doch
gestochen worden ist weil die Koalition
halt gerade im Moment ein paar
Schwierigkeiten hat Klimapolitik nicht
gegen die Bevölkerung sondern mit der
Bevölkerung machen sie nicht
Klimapolitik mit lastenabdruckventile
auf intelligente Art machen
sich zu Recht an einem Preis dafür zu
nennen was das CO2-Preis verursachen
würde weil sie nämlich den schützen
wollen würden ja weil ich finde den
falschen Weg halte weil wir sozusagen
von hunderten von Euro dann sprechen und
ungefähr in der Situation wären in der
wir im Herbst letzten Jahres waren wo
wir 200 Milliarden bereitstellen mussten
das auch ein Fehler war weil die
energiepreisbremse ja auch mit der
Gießkanne Geld durchs Land verteilt also
leute wie Sie und unternehmer
brauchen als wenn sie die Leute fragen
die haben Preise durch die Decke
gegangen sind im Herbst dann werden die
Ihnen antworten es war kein Fehler dass
sie eine entsprechend staatliche
Unterstützung kriegen und dann komme
immer noch sagen bei all den Dingen die
gehört gleichzeitig passieren man hätte
in Italien noch handwerklich besser
machen können aber es ist uns gelungen
uns unabhängig zu machen von russischen
Öl von russischer Kohle von russischem
Erdgas es ist gelungen dass das alles
ohne Schwierigkeiten durch den Winter
gegangen ist es ist sind Milliarden an
Unterstützung für die Leute ausgeht
reicht worden und da kommen immer noch
sagen es hätte zielgenauer passiert sein
aber der Winter ist viel besser
verlaufen als gedacht alle erwartet
haben und zwar weil das Wetter geholfen
hat Klaus Müller der Chef der
Bundesnetzagentur auch aber man kann
heute keine gefangen aber man kann auch
paranoid sozusagen alles schlecht machen
was sozusagen funktioniert
verboten kommen die Leute überfordern
finanziell überfordern
ihre Antwort darauf ist ein CO2 Preis
der zu Preisen für die was im Herbst
letzten Jahres hatten und das sozusagen
machen wir nicht mit mir weil wir
sozusagen die Leute nicht in die Armut
stürzen wollen wenn Sie die Leute in die
Armut stürzen wollen dann ist es Ihre
Entscheidung aber nicht unsere
Entscheidung